this year's nominees were announced
[Music]
next month's awards could look like an
episode of the x-files harry styles and
his one time
lover both nominated taylor swifts with
five knots
harry three there's so many exciting
things coming up that i can't wait to
share
i want a boyfriend selena gomez is also
among the nominees
so are her exes justin bieber with four
noms
the weeknd with six both guys are
competing for artist of the year
[Music]
demi lovato and joe jonas who also dated
taylor
are also both nominees
the new dad and his two bros up against
this powerhouse two sun
[Music]
gaga and ariana drenched in vma love
today soaking up
the most nods with nine each including
best collaboration
video and song of the year i'm a savage
i was shot in both of my feet still
healing from her gunshot wounds
megan the stallion is up for three
nominations
i'm happy
[Music]
and looks like billy eilish also got
everything she wanted
up for six awards including video of the
year for her moody hit
which the 18 year old directed herself
[Music]
the show's back in new york but this
year expect changes
it'll be held in multiple small venues
will still be live with recorded
elements
and likely a limited audience but we're
told fans will still take part
there are also two new categories best
quarantine performance and
best music video from home john legend's
up for both for his duet
and his fan source video